Angelina Jolie is opening up about her
latest health struggles for the first
time after a tumultuous year for
September's issue of Vanity Fair the
Hollywood star reveals she was diagnosed
with Bell's palsy in 2016
the condition is a temporary facial
paralysis it affects about 40,000
Americans each year the actress says she
has now recovered Jolie said quote
sometimes women and families put
themselves last until it manifests
itself in their own health our dr. David
agus joins us from Los Angeles
good morning so what are some of the
causes of Bell's palsy
well Bell's palsy is a case of the whole
not being big enough a nerve comes off
the brain through a small hole in this
hole in the skull and when it gets
inflamed its function is compromised and
it could get inflamed from predominantly
we think viral infections
Angelina David says that acupuncture
helped her recover that she use as a
treatment is that a common way to treat
it and are there other methods well most
of the time it resolves on its own three
to four weeks sometimes up to six months
you can give steroids or antivirals
which can probably shorten the duration
but acupuncture has been tried in
several trials and unfortunately it
didn't work I think time itself is the
great healer for Bell's palsy generally
how long does it take I mean it is it
vary among individuals varies among
individuals you know first described in
the 1820s by a Scottish surgeon who last
name was Bell and sometimes it takes two
to three weeks to go away and sometimes
up to several months but that
inflammation when it goes down the nerve
starts working in most cases but in this
Vanity Fair interview she seems to
suggest that it was caused by stress is
that one of the causes well certainly
when you're stressed viruses can come
out we know you can get shingles or and
reoccurrence of chickenpox when you're
very stressed and so there may be an
association with viruses and stress but
it's hard to know this is a pretty
common disorder Bell's palsy
are there long term effects in a very
small number of people the nerve won't
regain its former function and then
things like botulinum toxin or surgery
can help in those cases but in almost
90% of cases there's full
I have heard to back to Nora's point
that stress is a very big factor are you
saying that stress is not the most
common cause what stress itself doesn't
cause Bell's palsy I mean what we think
is that it's a viral infection of the
nerve coming through that hole in the
skull but can stress lower your
resistance to viruses potentially maybe
this is off the wall and not part of
this conversation but I was not no
morning I know exactly I was listening
this morning to the BBC on radio and
they were talking about a medical
journal in Britain and which had said
that the idea of taking by taking
medicine and and not taking all the
pills antibodies for example is no
longer necessarily good advice well it's
a big debate you know among doctors now
and in the scientific literature whether
you should complete an entire course of
antibiotics so say I prescribe you a
week of a z-pack and after three-four
days you're better do you have to do the
next three days we have thought that you
want to kill all the bacteria and that
you would get resistance if you don't
but in this case it's debatable and so
there's data on both sides all right
thank you Dave oh it's good to see you
dr. David agus thank you guys